the last shall be the first they say
I'll be brief I'll be brief for the
simple reason that my statement has
nothing to do with what we've heard I'm
a historian I'm not a conservation
person and what I propose is to bring
back history into the whole matter
because for obvious reasons you can do
very proper conservation without ever
dealing with history and there's nothing
wrong with that what's wrong is at the
other end most of the people who consume
this heritage and I'm thinking
especially of tourists have no notion of
history and therefore there's a
historical void that I think needs to be
filled if we want to have some kind of a
proper policy with respect to to
heritage and this is especially true in
some countries like mine I come from
Istanbul where the political pressure
and the pressure of the market that is
of tourism is such that it overshadows
to a large extent what we should call a
proper historical take on heritage let
me give you just a very short example
very concrete example the two most
visited monuments of Istanbul are aya
sofia the byzantine i don't i associate
which is the Byzantine Basilica which
you probably all know the other is top a
palace the palace of the the Imperial
Palace of the ottoman dynasty they're
visited there by approximately five
million people every year more or less
equally the two for all the wrong
reasons the Western tourist goes to I as
a fee had to admire the remains of a
long-lost Byzantine Christian
civilization Turks visiting aya sofya
lament over the music Asian of what they
think should be a trophy of their
conquests of the city of Constantinople
in 1453 for the Palace of top it's the
exact reverse in the sense that
Europeans go and visit it because they
want to find the exotics ISM and
neuroticism of some kind of an
Orientalist fantasy and the Turks
visited because they think it is the
of their own past so in the middle of
these two monuments lies the the
archeological Museum which receives
approximately a tenth of what these two
monuments receive in terms of tourists
and half of those are chain gangs of
great schools students who are forced to
go there as part of their educational
program so there is a problem and this
problem has to do with the fact that
history has become marginalized to the
point of becoming an accessory to the
political intentions of a government and
a state or the market orientations of a
tourist driven heritage understanding of
heritage in the Turkish case I can
assure you that the way in which Turkish
history has completely eaten up its
Ottoman past and everything that came
before it
negating in a sense anything that was
not Turkish or Islamic is an extremely
destructive process that has done much
more I think in terms of harm to the
heritage than any war many say snake or
any other natural or man-made
catastrophe because what politics does
to you and what ideology and this
distortion of history does is a very
insidious way of basically diverting the
choices and the priorities in a field
that is absolutely crucial towards what
is considered to be part of the grand
narrative and you have therefore a
division of the whole thing between the
grand narrative of the nation viewed by
Turkish politicians and by Turkish
nationalism and then you have the grand
narrative of a Eurocentric European
vision of world civilization these two
narratives are squeezing the reality of
history out of heritage I think what
universities need to do therefore is to
bring back history and good history in
order to have a less biased and a more
concrete understanding of what this
heritage stands for and try to correct
all the wrongs that have been done to
this day otherwise we end up with a
situation as I said where the government
is manipulating history to promote its
own vision of things and
the West is turning Turkey or other
countries into some kind of a provider
of raw materials for a Western centered
a narrative of history which is also
some things that completely dissociates
the local population from that heritage
thank you